how do the presidential candidates feel
about science on November the 8th voters
will decide whether Hillary Clinton or
Donald Trump will lead the country it's
pretty clear what Hillary Clinton thinks
about science science Donald Trump he's
said some things and then he's
contradicted them and anyway the
president is only a part of the election
equation plenty of other positions in
the government are also up for grabs
most seats in the two governing bodies
the House and the Senate are being
contested this year but scientists
should keep an eye on a few positions in
particular Senator Barbara Mikulski of
Maryland is retiring after 30 years
she's a senior Democrat and an advocate
for space and earth science she oversees
the Senate panel that determines funding
for NASA and the government's oceans
agency another Democrat will likely
replace her but they won't have her
influence then there's Senator Kelly
Ayotte in a tight race in New Hampshire
she's a rare breed a Republican
politician who accepts that climate
change is man-made if she loses it will
be to a Democrat with good green cred
but the Republicans will lose a pro
climate science voice from their ranks
and keep an eye on Missouri where Roy
Blunt is fighting for his Senate seat
he's the senator in charge of the panel
that sets funding for the National
Institutes of Health and he's pushed to
increase Tosh for the agency in recent
years so as November draws nearer keep
an eye on Maryland New Hampshire and
Missouri as well as on the White House
you